it's the capital of the state of
Amazonas and it has become an example of
the failure Brazil has to cope with
covet 19 thousands of victims of the
disease are being buried in the cemetery
every day William Almeida lost his ankle
in the past days he has now been
authorized to bury him here with similar
orders enter Harden the bodies are being
buried together in these mass graves
they're left in containers there are
three containers here sometimes the
funeral home staff can't come in they
stay by the interest in the coffins are
stored inside these containers until
they can be buried on the same day
relatives of those who died say the
names of those buried were being put in
the wrong coffins
Kovach 19 apparently arrived to the city
in the heart of the Amazon imported by a
woman who traveled from London one month
and a half later hospitals are trying to
cope with a spiralling increase of
infections Jorge Akal says the whole
system is failing manaus had an average
of 28 to 35 burials per day now it's
more than 120 it doesn't mean that all
these people are dying from Kovach 19
there are other causes of death but it's
not being checked the post-mortem
examination system is lacking far-right
presidency also Nauru is a strong
opponent of isolation and has dismissed
the virus poses a real threat for Brazil
hello I'm Sebastian Salgado famous
Brazilian photojournalist Sara del
Salgado and dozens of public figures
signed an open letter to the Brazilian
government calling on officials to
protect the nation's indigenous people
with limited access to health care they
say they are at risk of genocide many
indigenous communities are located not
far away from Manaus unfortunately I
don't see it with good eyes the doctors
the professionals some government
officials are trying to do their best
but I think things will worsen until the
6th or 8th of May the curve will
continue to rise
a curve that has already taken thousands
of lives in a country where the
president seems to be on denial about
the tragedy his people are facing every
day perishable Al Jazeera